he's the hero we've all been waiting for
who exactly was behind the incredible
holding out for a hero number in
euphoria and just how much went into
bringing all that jazz to life we've got
the dates on how it all came together
number one
who knew austin abrams had it in him
all the credit in the world goes to ryan
and austin the unexpected star of season
2 episode 7 has performed live theater
before but never anything quite as
intense and epic as the holding out for
a hero number we saw him perform he
certainly was going all out in the
version we saw on screen but the fact is
he kept that up for a significant amount
of time over three days it took a lot of
physical exertion i was doing that dance
a million times over those days but i
loved the dance i loved the guys i was
dancing with and it felt very real the
actor had a particular connection with
the song that helped motivate him as
well he first fell in love with it when
it was featured in shrek 2 oh so many
years ago so how was it actually having
a huge audience watching him like this i
loved the energy exchange between the
performers and the actors and the
audience because there was a crowd there
but of course nerves played a part and
the actor was terrified when it came
time to perform but he also couldn't
help but be totally excited oh and
luckily he had a bit more clothing on
than he'd originally anticipated the
initial script had the actor performing
in just his underwear so getting to don
the football gear was a definite relief
making the nerves just a bit better
number two
all hail this dancing queen ryan
heffington was a part of the number so
no doubt it was going to be something
special and it turned out to be a
highlight for the choreographer as well
i don't know if i've loved a piece this
much in a long time fabulous as it is
the dancing is uh well pretty suggestive
heffington knew what he was getting
himself into it might make people feel
uncomfortable a little bit but i'm fine
with that a major part of the
inspiration for the staging came from
the music itself and this music was not
shy it told me what it wanted to be i
guess according to the first script
though we were going to get something
very uh well oily there was a lot of
massaging in body oil according to
hafington this kind of direction made it
clear he didn't have to hold back one
bit
number three
everyone had a hard time getting through
this without laughing jacob allordy had
a particularly hard job though since he
was supposed to be acting all broody and
tough
not so easy when watching this circus
perhaps these people kind of just
staring at you just laughing and
pointing at you it could have felt awful
but in fact o'lordy was just overwhelmed
by how impressive his co-star was it was
tough not to crack a smile watching the
drama of the dance and i was like
yes abrams was parodying his character
but it was hard to ignore that sheer
talent every time the ferocity and
intensity just went up and up and up it
never lacked and it's pretty obvious
from what we see on screen elordi wasn't
the only one to enjoy though most of the
reactions we see in the audience from
the cast members were completely real
their characters might not have been
such big bands of the play in the end
but for the euphoria cast this made for
one of the most memorable times on set
she's brilliant next is brilliant
number four
not everyone had such a great time days
on the euphoria set are notoriously long
and for the extras who have to endure
filming it's not such a great deal one
extra from the set went to tiktok to
reveal what it was really like behind
the scenes 16 hour filming days
exhausted performers to the point that
some of them actually left the set
making for inconsistencies in the
audience throughout the seventh episode
the play in the audience scenes actually
took forever for them to film like it
took weeks for them to film just this
episode which is honestly crazy included
with those performers that walked off
set was dominic feik who actually had a
lookalike in his place for part of the
episode
while everyone did earn a bit of extra
cash for those overtime hours it didn't
really make up for the fact that no one
was warned just how long their work day
would be
number five
keep the cameras rolling you never know
what might be captured while the magic
of the performance was mainly thanks to
heffington and abrams sam levinson had
to do his due diligence to record it all
well enough to do it justice cameras
were everywhere and endless hours were
spent making sure every shot was nailed
and every angle seen there were the
audience reactions to capture all the
dancers on stage and of course all those
close-ups of austin rocking out safety
was key as well the costume designer
heidi bivens and production designer
jason baldwin stewart were both
consulted in the making so each element
was safe for the performers all that oil
that was part of the original plan got
replaced with water when it became
obvious that oil wouldn't really set up
anyone for success this number was by
far one of the best things we've seen on
euphoria we're all for more musical
numbers with these talents around what
was your favorite part of lexi's play